thank you
[Music]
this is probably going to be one of the
worst things we see today oh good oh no
let's get it out the way Anthony article
it's not quite it makes sense it's not
full Anthony
rise up is the most tragic and they're
real stories I just have a better way of
you know I make it sound lighter yeah
so there's a San Antonio police officer
who uh was recently fired after
um shooting at a teenager who was doing
absolutely nothing other than eating
McDonald's in his car oh in his car and
you know when you hear these news
stories now you think yeah right he
probably had was a suspect and had a gun
in his seat this time
no he was just a kid eating McDonald's
in his car the officer was looking for a
different guy thought it was him the kid
got scared because the officer was like
trying to he opened his door and was
basically like had his gun out so the
kid freaked out uh he reversed to like
he put his hand on the steering wheel
and then the officer started shooting
whoa what the [ __ ] was the car the car
started moving yeah and the officer
freaked out and auto but in the report
the officer wrote that um that the car
was like gonna hit him so that's why he
shot but let's look at the video and see
first off oh man dude
foreign
get out of the car what
what oh my God it's on fire stop fire
shots fired
what the [ __ ] dude
shots fired
is that kid alive he uh is in critical
condition oh my god dude cops are
[ __ ] nuts so quickly so as it turns
out uh the cops the cop said the officer
approached the car because he thought it
was the same vehicle that allegedly
evaded police the day before
um the someone had called for a
disturbance at the McDonald's and that
wasn't the disturbance it was something
completely different and they just
thought that that kid was the thing
people were calling for the teen
suffered multiple gunshot wounds taken
the hospital in critical
um he was initially charged with evading
detention and assault on a police
officer [ __ ] you but then since then
they dismissed the charges and they
fired the uh they terminated the cop oh
wow does the the uh car uh the cop have
a partner or no um it does not in the
you don't see it in the video but that
might be the person who's describing the
report of what that guy did it could be
the partner like giving his account
because they're saying like the cop said
the officer did this so it might be the
cop just gets fired right nothing
happens to him right
you mean like as far as charges yeah so
far just getting sacked yes
but we're getting terminated is better
than paid leave which is what they
usually do yeah that's true it's a step
up ready yeah usually it's like hey yeah
we suspended them but we're just gonna
keep making like eight thousand dollars
a month while we used to spend them for
like two months in this case one nation
in this case when they fire him is that
do he does he get severance
I don't know I think it's probably like
the military type of thing where if it's
like some sort of dishonorable discharge
you probably don't yeah you can't get
Severance for that kind of turn because
that would suck because then it's like
either paid leave or paid to leave
what kind of training is this dude I
know dude that thing's [ __ ] crazy he
just that was poor kid dude literally
unarmed sitting in his car eating
McDonald's by himself yeah and then
freaks out because he's like what the
[ __ ] did I do and then gets shot up like
that's crazy how Wild is it too it's
like the vehicle matches the description
of a car that maybe got away from us
yesterday
yeah like he's like he's like going in
weapons high like like immediately like
holy [ __ ] escalation is like this yeah
whereas I think the proper protocol is
like
like when you're a police officer you're
technically part of a team you're not
supposed to be [ __ ] Rambo so like
let's say there is a car that's like
that right yeah you call it in and it's
always better to Veer on like being less
violent than more violent
so you would probably call it in check
run the plates cool that's not he
probably would have found that's not the
one that evaded but like let's say yeah
like you don't want to get away it's too
crazy you could probably get one of your
other buddies to block off the
McDonald's so you kind of slowly like
like a python choke them out right this
is just [ __ ] strike like crazy you
know because that [ __ ] man that's so
many other options there's so many ways
you can slowly like control this
situation without having to use like the
gun should be like the last resort and
he still didn't even get the kid he's
still able to like drive off oh my God
so there was he didn't really do what he
needed to do
the gun sounded like the first Resort in
this guy exactly that guy shouldn't have
a boom that guy that that is the worst
thing I've ever seen like from a cop
that's [ __ ] insane yeah
yeah and it sucks that like did any part
of that looked like assault on a police
officer no no but I'm not surprised that
that was immediately drummed up yeah at
all it just shows how they operate a
little bit much salt on a police officer
plus I wonder you know not to suppose
too much but there's no way this cop has
any remorse about it he's probably like
an active situation you have to focus
you know what I mean like you said it's
San Antonio San Antonio yeah what do you
think the family's gonna press charges
oh uh I hope they do I hope they do too
this kid went to critical [ __ ] I hope
they do he's in critical from gunshots
his life's not it's gonna have some
lasting games for what and for what for
what for [ __ ] McChicken Deluxe
gun rights in Texas I'm the the uh the
victim in this situation like
um is it like assumed for police in
Texas to be like people are armed like
you know what I mean his he has an
ability to respond that quick as well
no you got to see something yeah like he
was obviously eating you see that in the
video you see the rapping both of his
games
and then not only that he actually tried
putting it on the steering wheel before
things got all hectic I think he was
like a crazy that's why I asked if he
was like if you had a partner because it
seemed like he's like a super spaz
rookie because if you're a super spaz
rookie you're usually assigned to a
partner that goes on patrol with you for
two years so that you don't like like
for example one time
um me silent Mike and two of my other
friends were driving on Monterey pass
car pulls uh pulls us over because the
car matched the description of a car
that was just in a robbery
so they pull this over they make all of
us sit on the curb and then the guy that
told us to get out was like very very
aggressive you know and then
um but we were all compliant oh [ __ ]
like if it looks like the car that was
in a robbery I mean yeah go ahead like
check make sure we're good because we
didn't Rob any house around here we're
just literally going home so we all sit
on the curb and then this guy was like
you know like very like aggressive sit
down or whatever whatever and then the
his training officer came out and then
he was like his tone of voice is way
different because I think he just seen
so much and then later I hear him pull
him out to the side and he goes I'm
pretty sure they're not the ones that
run and he was like you know he's like
well they're all wearing sandals and
they're all wearing basketball shirts so
I think just because you're experienced
you can kind of just put like little
things together right so you don't have
to be like [ __ ] like this but I think
he's kind of Spazzy where he's like that
I have a note maybe the training officer
should have been the first one to
interact with you guys not the [ __ ]
jittery rookie
hey everybody get out of the car
it's like Andy Griffith yeah like why is
the trading officer coming like 10
minutes later he's like he's like oh
okay yeah I see what's going on like it
should have been that guy but I think
they have to have to watch him like
maybe they she showed him a couple times
and now it's like your turn I love
that's so funny that guy was just so
like well you boys are driving a
suspicious vehicle yeah yeah
so you could just tell I'm like oh [ __ ]
I see why there's there's a huge
difference this guy's like first year on
the force yeah this guy's been on for 10
years and he could already just like be
a detective and there's no way these
guys stole and if you none of them are
even breaking a sweat they're wearing
you know yeah you can just tell right
off the bat there's so many
characteristics outside of like the
usual things that you would go oh like a
detective would know yeah there's like
no [ __ ] I don't know like dust or
grass or anything like like we've been
hopping fences the whole time right
right no signs dude every time you hear
about it's like oh they got they just
got the guy who uh who was from that
robbery I'm gonna think that like 10
[ __ ] other cars oh for sure stop
first and like nice people throw on the
street in their face
that's happened that's happened to me
and and my old dance crew when we were
in uh back in the day Azusa and Amar had
the only 24-hour McDonald's like in
SoCal it was just just those cross
streets so we would always drive all the
way out there to just have McDonald's
after practice and uh we got stopped and
and the cop put us all three of us in
the car just to check if we were the
ones in this like disturbance or robbery
that had happened in the area
and we were just [ __ ] having the time
of our lives acting like you know we're
just like cool fine this is kind of
funny whatever it's not us you know and
then it took like 30 minutes they had to
like actually catch the real guys first
it's like what the [ __ ] man like because
it sounded so weird to him that like all
of our IDs showed our cities that we
lived in were so far away so they were
like you mean you guys come out here
only to eat McDonald's oh yeah it's only
[ __ ] 24 hours when you you would know
that sir but then he was like in such
disbelief that like usually if you're
robbing an area you're not from it oh I
see yeah so it took a while to verify
but then you yeah really it's I wouldn't
be surprised like if we ran we'd
probably get shot at yeah or if they
didn't catch the other guys they would
have just been like yeah it was these
guys I know it is one of the toughest
jobs in the world because you're like
playing the [ __ ] Justice lady and
they're like [ __ ] what do I I don't have
I don't even have all the evidence I
just gotta [ __ ] heads or tails you
know and I get it that's why like I'm
not I wasn't upset I was like I
understand the process like I understand
that but in this [ __ ] situation oh
dude that's so crazy he didn't do very
much different than what I did or what
you did like it's very [ __ ] similar
especially the way he approached him too
right it took like 10 shots you know
yeah that's oh they always do fire like
75 shots it's like what the [ __ ] yeah I
don't even think that's protocol I think
protocol you're supposed to stand like
back where the gas tank is and then you
have them come out I show your hands
through the window first like if you do
want to get someone out right show your
hands through the window first now open
the car door from the outside
and then you put one foot out yeah it's
different when he's opening the car door
himself like of course it's gonna make
you panic yeah wait wait and also like
why if you're an officer you're you're
truly in fear of your life and you think
this person has a gun why would you walk
up to the car and open the door yourself
yeah oh yeah that is true yeah you don't
really see that too much the way he did
the way he approached everything yeah
you never see a cop yeah that's true
I've never seen that that would hell and
make anyone Panic I'm like just stop
watching too many [ __ ] movies bro
yeah because if you turn around and
you're like oh [ __ ] you you'd want to
get out too because it's [ __ ] you
just see a gut in your face yeah yeah
you don't even know if it's a it's a cop
at that point you're just reactive yeah
dude half the time I can't even [ __ ]
see that well so I would definitely
wouldn't know if it's a cop yeah
you gotta go fix your eyes
that's why I wear these dude
now you are now you are a cop
[Music]